monsieur kraz a servi à la présidence de
la république au commandement militaire
du palais en qualité de réserviste et
nous avons à lui poser quelques
questions pour éclairer la commission
sur le fonctionnement de ses services en
charge de la sécurité du palais
présidentiel qui sont des services qui
relève de la garde républicaine de la
gendarmerie nationale du ministère de
l'intérieur et du ministère de la
défense pour le recrutement des
collaborateurs qui y servent pour la
gestion de leurs moyens des carrières et
pour leur organisation
c'est seulement à ce titre que nous
recevons aujourd'hui monsieur kraz
monsieur crasse vous aviez demandé le
huis clos comme
la législation le permet cette demande a
été soumise à l'appréciation de la
commission des lois qui en a délibéré ce
matin avant de procéder aux auditions et
qui n'a pas souhaité accepter le huis
clos dans un souci de transparence
toutes les autres auditions ayant eu
lieu en public
néanmoins je vous rappelle que une
audition n'est pas une comparution
kissinmas horizon aucun procès que nous
nous prononçons aucune sanction et que
les questions que nous avons à vous
poser ne sont en réalité pas des
questions qui touchent à des faits qui
pourraient vous être reprochée nous
attendons de vous simplement que vous
nous apportiez de manière coopérative un
éclairage pour une audition qui n'est
peut-être pas la principale
parmi toutes celles auxquelles nous
avons eu l'occasion de procéder et
auquel nous continuerons à procéder
alors je suis obligé et je les fais pour
toutes les personnes auditionnées de
vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission des lois doté
des prérogatives d'une commission
denquête serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amande et je vais vous inviter à
prêter serment
je vous invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levé la main droite et dit je le jure je
le jure
oh mercy souhaitez vous monsieur kraz
vous exprimer avant que nous vous
posions quelques questions ce n'est pas
nécessaire
très bien alors je vais demander
maintenant à monsieur jean pierre sueur
ou à madame jourdain mal à mourad dans
ce cas c'est madame jourda qui va poser
les les premières questions de vous
poser quelques questions
merci messieurs président monsieur
crasse pouvez vous nous indiquer quels
sont votre formation votre parcours
professionnel notamment en matière de
sécurité et de protection rapprochée
s'il vous plaît monsieur crasse on
m'entend mon parcours professionnel des
buts en 1996 où je deviens enseignants
français en histoire géo dans un cfa
j'étais enseignant pendant neuf ans au
préalable j'avais effectué mon service
militaire dans l'armée de l'air dont
j'ai été réserviste jusqu'en 2005 où en
2005 j'intègre la réserve opérationnelle
de la gendarmerie nationale dans le
département de l'eure donc la
gendarmerie départementale je peux
continuer j'ai eu aussi une formation
j'ai passé un indé huppé diplôme
universitaire professionnelle dans la
sécurité privée dans le métier
d'enquêteur privé panthéon assas moulin
madame jourdain
oui d'accord dans quelles mesures
avez-vous été associés à la campagne du
candidat emmanuel macron et tests comme
prestataire ou comme salarié et quelle
était la nature de vos prestations de
base j'étais associé donc à la campagne
présidentielle du candidat macron à
partir de septembre fin septembre
octobre 2016
en tant que bénévole dans un premier
temps mais mon rôle était dans un
premier temps d'accompagner le service
d'ordre
gt gt avec monsieur benalla donc qui
était dans le service d'ordre
je recrutais notamment les bénévoles du
service d'ordre on avait fait un appel à
volontaires sur la base des listes
d'adhérents que nous avions et nous
avons ainsi recruter et former des
bénévoles pour assister le service
d'ordre lors des meetings et pour
assurer l'accueil
j'insiste sur le mot d'accueil au
quartier général de la baie groulx à
partir du moment où nous nous sommes
installés là-bas le 15 novembre 2016 je
vous remercie madame jourdain ouï
là c'était dans un premier temps vous
nous avez indiqué comme bénévole et
ensuite vous allez voilà j'ai été
prestataire pour la république enfin en
marche à l'époque et le 1er juillet 2010
est je suis devenu salarié de en marche
donc après la victoire présidentielle je
vous remercie madame jourda oui c'était
précisément le sens de ma question
suivante depuis quand étiez-vous
employés au sein du mouvement la
république en marche qui vous avez
recruté et quelles fonctions exercées
vous monsieur kraz donc j'ai été
présentée par monsieur benalla donc
qu'il y avait qui étaient rentrés
antérieurement au sein du mouvement il
m'a alors comme nous nous connaissions
depuis 2009 il l'a dit tout à l'heure je
les jeux les rencontrer dans le cadre de
sa préparation militaire de gendarmerie
nous nous sommes toujours suivi
amicalement il m'a proposé de rejoindre
les rendent en marche et bien sûr c'est
pas lui qui a décidé tout j'ai été
adoubé en parler les gens qui étaient
qui faisait partie du staff
voilà pour m'occuper donc mes fonctions
vous vous posiez la question de mes
fonctions pour m'occuper notamment de la
gestion des bénévoles au sein du qg de
la baie groulx qui avait pour mission
d'assurer l'accueil des gens qui sonnait
et on a eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
visites pendant la campagne donc assurer
l'accueil et voulait regarder si toutes
les personnes qui accédaient au qg il y
avait quelque chose à faire
jourdas alors dernière question qui on
comprend plusieurs j'aurais souhaité
savoir dans quelles conditions vous
aviez rejoint en qualité de réserviste
le commandement militaire du palais de
l'elysée si vous aviez été recommandée
ou à payer pour cette affectation
ensuite combien de fois vous aviez été
convoqué en tant que réserviste à
l'elysée pour quelles missions et si
votre hiérarchie au sein du mouvement de
la république en marche était informé de
votre emploi en tant que réserviste à
l'elysée ça fait beaucoup d'eux beaucoup
de questions je vous écoute allez-y donc
je vais essayer de répondre
à toutes ces questions en formulant une
réponse globale donc je rencontre la
première fois le général bio-farina au
mois de septembre 2010 est sur la
recommandation d'alexandre benalla
puisqu'il y avait comme projet de monter
une structure de réserve au palais de
l'élysée structure de réserve donc qui
doit permettre de gonfler les effectifs
des gardes républicains qui sont des
militaires d'activé à chaque fois en
fait qu'un réserviste intervient il est
en trinôme avec deux gardes si vous
comprenez le sens de ma réponse donc le
but c'était de pouvoir gonfler les
effectifs sur des sur des événements
particuliers tels que les journées du
patrimoine mais aussi au quotidien
puisque les effectifs fourni de la garde
républicaine sont des fois je vais pas
dire insuffisant mais là ça permettait
d'avoir un peu plus de volume
je crois que monsieur benallal a dit
tout à l'heure tous les palais de la
république ont des réservistes notamment
le sénat vous avez des réservistes qui
viennent du 2e régiment d'infanterie
donc là le but était de proposer sous
forme d'appel à volontaires aux
réservistes du 1er régiment d'infanterie
de venir rejoindre le palais de l'elysée
et avec une particularité c'était que
cette mission élyséenne devait être
exclusive de toute autre pour des
raisons de confidentialité
donc je rencontre le général bio farina
nous discutons autour de ce projet il me
confie donc la mission
deux montées cette structure de
réservistes mais moi à cette époque là
je suis réservistes dans la
départementale 1 er ghn région de
gendarmerie de haute normandie
donc il a fallu faire transférer mon
dossier ce qui a pris un peu de temps
puisque l'administration militaire et
prend son temps pour faire les choses
dans l'ordre on va dire pour ne pas
précipiter les choses
j'ai commencé ma première journée de
réserve au palais de l'elysée le 10
novembre 2017
j'ai fait le 10 et le 11 novembre qui
étaient des journées de découverte on va
dire les plus exhaustive possible du
palais et des services pour bien
imprégné ensuite nous avons reçu des
candidats réservistes dont qui jeûnaient
du 1er régiment d'infanterie et qu'ils
étaient intéressés par cette mission
donc ils ont eu plusieurs filtres un
premier filtre avec moi et un autre
officier donc du sc eux le sc eux c'est
le service de contrôle des entrées qui
dépend du commandement militaire est la
mission principale de toute façon de ses
réservistes et de travailler au profit
du service de contrôle des entrées
premier filtre ensuite le deuxième
filtre une validation par le général
bio-farina lui-même qui étend le
l'autorité hiérarchique la plus haute
veut connaître tous les gens qui vont
travailler pour le commandement
militaire
donc les gens à porter leur cv et était
était entendue écoutée on leur poser des
questions et s'il donnait satisfaction
il intégrait après il avait quelques
journées d'observation tout de même
l'âme jourda oui vous n'avez pas
complètement répondu aux questions elles
étaient nombreuses à fait donc je me
permet de les reformuler je vous avais
demandé combien de fois vous avez été
convoqué en tant que réserviste
alors j'ai été il me semble je n'ai pas
le chiffre exact en tête mais une
quarantaine de fois je n'ai rien entre
40 et 50
danser ce nombre de jours de réserves
que j'ai effectués j'ai effectué 17
jours en bourgogne pour encadrer une pmg
avec en fait j'étais le chef de
détachement et moi il faut vous nous
disiez ce week-end
je parle beaucoup par acronyme dans
l'armée fin dans la gendarmerie c'est un
peu comme sa préparation militaire de
gendarmerie c'est à dire qu'on prend des
jeunes volontaires issus du civil qui
n'ont pas de formation militaire puisque
le service militaire n'existe plus et
quand un certain nombre de jours on va
les amener
c'est une formation qui est très intense
il n'y a pas de ya pas de temps mort je
peux vous le dire on va les amener à
être aux premiers stable on va dire
premier stade opérationnel qui puisse
intégrer après une unité mais le
principe dans la réserve opérationnelle
c'est que la formation et continue c'est
à dire que les gens sont toujours tester
les gens sont toujours fort mais le tir
est obligatoire une fois par an si vous
n'avez pas votre tir validé vous ne
pouvez plus travailler donc je reviens
sur mon propos donc j'ai fait 17 jours
en bourgogne à dijon sur la base
aérienne par l'école de gendarmerie de
dijon qui est sur l'ancienne base
aérienne pour former un détachement de
gardes républicains
ce qui m'a permis de sélectionner fin de
pré sélectionner des candidats
potentiels pour pour la garde de
l'elysée pour lacer espère là encore un
acronyme compagnie de sécurité de la
présidence de la république à bourg d'à
oui et donc la dernière question était
votre hiérarchie au sein du mouvement la
république en marche et l informer de
votre emploi en tant que réserviste
je n'en faisais pas un secret donc oui
je pense que tout à fait il était tout à
fait au courant de 2 mon activité au
palais je remercie monsieur jean pierre
sueur monsieur le président suit les
questions de de muriel jourda
si je comprends bien les 14 réserves
hills qui a été recruté par le général
bio farina n'a fait pas une mission
clairement défini c'était une série de
missions qui étaient définis de manière
aléatoire ou un monsieur le sénateur au
jour le jour où il y avait une mission
précise monsieur le sénateur jeu est
précisé que tous les réservistes donc
les quatorze réservistes travaille
exclusivement au profit du sc service du
contrôle des entrées c'est à dire que
tout le monde ici je pense connaît le
palais d'evreux vous avez la loge
d'honneur qui donne sur le faubourg vous
avez la loge est la loge l'ouest vous
avez des emprises extérieur mais qui
sont dans le périmètre à marigny où sur
la rue de l'elysée donc ces jeunes
réservistes travailler exclusivement au
profit du contrôle des entrées de ces
différents points donc la mission en
bourgogne était exceptionnel pour moi a
été exceptionnelle pour eux non pour eux
en fait c'était leur formation initiale
oui c'était le premier sas de leur
formation
d'accord très bien je voulais vous poser
deux autres questions lors de vos
travaux au sein du commandement
militaire de l'elysée aviez-vous à
traiter pour l'émission que vous
exerciez avec monsieur alexandre benalla
alors avec alexandre benalla que je ne
voyais pas tous les jours ce qu'il a
du tout le même emploi du temps que moi
on se côtoyait on se voyait on se
croisait mais par exemple je n'ai aucun
souvenir d'avoir eu le temps de déjeuner
avec lui un midi lors de toutes mes
journées puisque j'étais moi même
j'étais moi même assez occupé est lui
aussi dans mais c'est arrivé bien sûr
mais on n'a jamais eu le temps même de
déjeuner ensemble donc formation était
purement informel et amicales oui parce
qu'il n'ya pas de lien hiérarchique au
sein du palais entre lui et moi je
dépend entièrement du commandement
militaire et donc du général bio farina
et donc de
d autres officiers qui mais vous savez
et une bonne connaissance de monsieur
benalla tout à fait nous nous
connaissons depuis 2009
alors est-ce que à votre avis parce que
vous savez nous posons beaucoup de
questions et nous recherchons vous savez
nous mêmes la vérité le plus possible de
nous approcher de la vérité de regarder
les dysfonctionnements qui ont lieu de
voir les propositions que nous pouvons
faire c'est notre travail est ce qu'à
votre avis il a exercé des missions de
organisation de déplacements
exclusivement ou est-ce qu'ils
exerçaient des missions de police et de
sécurité
alors monsieur le sénateur je pense que
vous avez auditionné beaucoup de monde
très longue amant monsieur benalla ce
matin et qu'il a eu tout le loisir de
répondre à cette question
moi je me réserve le droit de ne pas y
répondre
très bien mais puisque vous le côtoyer
que vous le connaissiez vous avez
peut-être une idée sur la question j'ai
forcément is game élevé vous savez vire
la vérité jules je dis la vérité mais je
ne suis pas monsieur bénard je suis
monsieur kraz oui d'accord mais quand
vous avez une connaissance du sujet bien
sûr que je vous pose et vous pouvez
répondre en toute sincérité
ça me concerne en rien monsieur le
sénateur et au fond monsieur mais je
croise vous vous estimez que de votre
balcon de l'endroit où vous étiez vous
ne pouviez pas apprécier la réalité de
la fonction de monsieur benalla je ne
connais pas sa fiche de poste je n'ai
pas lu son
son contrat de travail donc je ne vais
pas me risquer à dire des approximations
très bien monsieur le président excusez
moi d'insister vous étiez à l'elysée
vous le connaissiez bien vous pouvez
nous dire si de ce qu'il faisait et on
nous à vous savez on nous a tout dit et
donc nous devons rechercher la vérité
on nous a présenté je les ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois comme une sorte vous
savez de gentils organisateurs de
voyages comme dans une organisation qui
célèbre il est très gentil je vous le
confirme non mais je ne porte pas de
jugement au mois deux sur ce sujet de et
voilà une information en tout cas que
vous nous avez donné on nous a aussi on
a eu des éléments qui ont montré qu'ils
avaient des fonctions de sécurité à
commencer par le permis de port d'armes
donc vous saviez bien les choses comme
un bout ne pas vous dire je ne savais
rien vous savez bien que ce n'est pas
rare et monsieur le sénateur même si je
sais c'est chose je ne vous y répondrait
pas très bien écoutez je prends acte de
votre réponse alors d'autres questions
madame jourda oui cette fois ci c'est
vraiment la dernière je voulais savoir
monsieur cratie danse au sein de cette
cellule de réserve il y avait d'autres
salariés éventuellement la république en
marche et si c'est le cas comment
ont-ils été recrutés et ce par votre
intermédiaire vous ont ils été
recommandée alors il n'y a pas dans
l'es14 de salariés de la république en
marche
en revanche il y a il y à un réserviste
que j'ai connus lors de la campagne et
qui connaissent en ma qualité de
réserviste m'a posé des questions m'a
dit c'est mon rêve depuis longtemps etc
etc
et comme c'est quelqu'un donc que j'ai
eu l'occasion de former à dijon et dont
je connais la droiture et j'ai pu
apprécier les qualités professionnelles
pendant cette formation je les jeux les
recommandés oui il a passé par contre
comme les autres l'entretien avec moi et
avec un autre officier et l'entretien
avec le général
il n'y a pas eu de il n'y a pas eu de
passe droit en aucun droit s'il avait
été mauvais il a été mauvais on croit
pas le risque de prendre quelqu'un qui
est pas à eux au maximum de ce qu'on
exige parce que on est quand même au
palais de l'elysée merci de ces
premières réponses monsieur grosdidier
le on est un peu surpris est-ce que
c'était surtout une pratique habituelle
que le semaine alan zach tu étais tout à
l'heure qu'il fallait ouvrir presque à
la société civile les services de
protection de la présidence de la
république
on pensait jusqu'à présent qu'on avait
les l'idée des plus professionnelles des
professionnels non pas parce que la
réserve de la gendarmerie n'est pas
parfaitement honorable on apprécie
beaucoup son intervention sur l'ensemble
des territoires mais parce qu'on est là
dans les missions les plus délicates qui
concerne ne le sommet de l'état alors
dire qu'ils qui a au départ manifester
cette volonté d'ouvrir à des moins
professionnel la protection de la
présidence de la république
et est-ce que ça concerne
essentiellement des sympathisants du
mouvement politique de majorité
présidentielle ou est ce que c'est une
pratique très ouverte sur un ensemble d
des réservistes de la gendarmerie
indépendamment de toute considération
partisane alors monsieur le sénateur
j'essayais pareil de faire une réponse
globale à toutes vos interrogations
il n'y a pas dans l'es14 de sympathie
face il y en a un que j'ai connu pendant
la campagne mais c'est tout tous les
autres sont des gens que j'ai connus
soit lors de cet appel à volontariat qui
viennent du 1er régiment est captée déjà
des réservistes soit des gens que j'ai
recruté de moi même que j'ai prérecruter
présélectionnés de moi même lors de la
préparation militaire de gendarmerie et
je leur ai pas demandé si c'était
adhérents en marche
une première question deuxième question
vous étonné de la présence de
réservistes donc au palais de l'elysée
en fait je vais pas parler je ne suis
pas je ne suis pas un grand spécialiste
des réserves militaires
mais aujourd'hui l'état des forces
armées qu'elles soient terre air mer
gendarmerie nécessite l'emploi de
réservistes parce que on connaît les
difficultés
voilà on connaît les difficultés que vit
notre armée je pense que sans l'apport
de la réserve opérationnelle qu'elle
soit air-air mère gendarmerie elle
serait encore plus grande donc l'apport
de réservistes jg une très grande page
une très grande gêne plus grande
expérience de la départementale puisque
j'ai passé 13 ans je peux vous dire que
l'apport des réservistes est absolument
essentiel merci de votre réponse madame
benbassa merci monsieur le président
j'ai deux questions à vous poser l'une
la halle à propos de la tribe
oui à propos de l'attribution de votre
statut d'observateur qui soulève des
questions puisque monsieur bruno roger
petit alors pour parole de l'elysée nous
expliquer que vous possédiez
effectivement une autorisation pour les
observateurs
tandis que monsieur le général bio
farina a démenti cette information
comment expliquez vous ces différentes
versions et deuxièmement par curiosité
je voudrais savoir si vous êtes toujours
membres de l'are m
et vu que les statuts de votre parti
stipulent que lorsque l'un de ses
adhérents comme un acte préjudiciable au
mouvement
celui ci doit être entendu par une
commission disciplinaire interne de
nombreux militants ont pas ce processus
déjà subi une procédure d'exclusion qu
en est il
dans votre cas alors attends pardon je
vous prie de m'excuser et je prie madame
benbassa de m'en excuser aussi mais la
question sur le titre que vous pouviez
avoir ou pas à participer même en
qualité d'observateur au la présence
policière
le 1er mai nous sommes convenus que
c'était trop proche de l'enquêté
judiciaire pour que vous ayez à répondre
à ce type de question mais vous devez en
revanche répondre à la deuxième question
de madame ménard de madame benbassa
merci monsieur le président c'est la
réponse que je m'apprêtais à faire
madame la sénatrice pour la deuxième
question est ce que je suis encore
salarié de la ramenons puisque j'ai été
licencié j'ai été licencié le bar est ce
qu'on peut dire le 31 juillet parce que
j'ai eu mon entretien préalable à
licenciement à 11 heures mais à huit
heures du matin ils étaient déjà annoncé
que j'étais licencié bon donc ça a été
un peu un peu baroque
concernant le fait que je sois toujours
militant je ne sais pas je reçois encore
des mails en tant qu'adhérent donc
j'imagine que oui mais s'ils décident de
me + m'ont envoyé je ne le serais plus
je vous remercie madame leur billet
monsieur kraz quand eux il y a une
mission à pourvoir
y at il des feuilles de route bien
précise et y at il des rapports à rendre
au terme de toutes les missions en
général alors une mission de réserve se
prévoit al avance dans dans les
meilleurs délais possibles quand cela
est possible mais des fois ça peut être
un peu plus rapide
toutes les missions font l'objet d'une
convocation on a un logiciel qui nous
permet de remplir en ligne
la réalité de cette mission qui doit
être validé par l'autorité d'emploi
parce que si on veut se faire payer
il faut qu'on puisse prouver qu'on a
bien réaliser cette mission
donc il ya des services de gestion qui
s'occupe de ça moi j'étais notamment
donc je dépends des du 1er régiment
d'infanterie à nanterre donc c'est eux
qui gèrent et tout a été validé en temps
et en heure pas d'autres questions
mais si madame train de l'est merci
monsieur le président juste une
précision monsieur kraz on vous a posé
la question tout à l'heure qui était à
l'initiative de constituer cette
structure de réserviste au départ est ce
que vous le savez je pense que c'est le
général en accord bien sûr avec les
autorités du palais et il faut voir
alors je vais je veux pas parler à la
place et du général bio farina et du
dggn du directeur de la gendarmerie
nationale mais je pense que il y à
l'aspect opérationnel le renforts
opérationnels que les réservistes
peuvent apporter qui est très important
et il ya aussi un côté attractivité
puisque la gendarmerie nationale est
constamment en recherche de réservistes
donc
montrer que des réservistes peut être
intégré au palais nationaux et notamment
à l'elysée
c'est une sorte de vitrine qui peut être
intéressante mais le premier aspect
c'est réellement l'aspect opérationnel
qui permet de renforcer les gendarmes
d'activ qui ont des emplois du temps
qui sont assez costaud dès qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui est malade qui absent où
il ya des permissions à prendre il faut
pouvoir occuper de façon optimum tous
les postes une dernière question
et lorsque vous effectuiez votre service
au titre de la réserve pour palais de
l'elysée vous étiez donc vous aussi
comme les autres réservistes préposé à
une tâche de contrôle des entrées à
l'elysée à l'occasion de cette mission
vous n'étiez donc jamais en contact avec
le gspr et vous n'aviez pas non plus
d'autres activités au sein du palais mon
activité principale au sein du palais
c'est là le commandement de mai
réservistes c'est à dire aller vérifier
qu'ils sont bien la leur vérifiez que la
prise en compte de leur armement se
fasse dans les conditions prévues par
les textes de vérifier j'allais
constamment voir si fin j'étais pas
toujours derrière non plus pour les pour
les flics et entre guillemets mais je
vérifier auprès des gendarmes d'actifs
dégradés
si ces jeunes réservistes faisait bien
leurs services s'il était si c'était
police ils étaient courtois puisque
c'est ce qu'on leur demande
aux entrées donc je m'occupais
principalement de ceux là après
lorsqu'il y avait des événements type
dîner officiel
je me rappelle par exemple aussi du one
planet smit qui devait être en novembre
ou en décembre
je prêtaient main forte aux officiers
alors on peut le voir sur les images je
suis toujours en civil puisque les
officiers ou les cadres du est ce que
nous sommes en civil alors que les gens
qui sont dans les loges et jean jérôme
d'actifs sont en tenue d'uniforme
moi j'étais en civil et je prêtais
concours je faisais le le même travail
que mes camarades d'activ qui contrôlent
les entrées 1 quand ya des des gros flux
de véhicules qui rentre on est là pour
vérifier avec tous les véhicules sont
bien les bons avec les bonnes plaques
d'immatriculation et que ce sont les
bonnes personnes qui rentrent au sein du
palais d'evreux je vous remercie celles
ci de madame marie madame marie mercier
madame benbassa vous aviez déjà posé une
question mais je vais vous redonner la
parole
merci monsieur le président pouvez vous
nous préciser votre grade exacte et dans
l'es14 réservistes que vous aviez il y
avait-il des lieutenants colonels
vous pouvez répondre monsieur grâce je
suis chef d'escadron donc ce qui
correspond à commandant 4 4 barrettes
voilà et dans les réservistes que je
commandais il pouvait pas y avoir de
lieutenant-colonel puisqu'il aurait été
supérieur à moi il n'y avait de mémoire
que des brigadiers brigadier-chef
première classe ou même des ce qu'on
appelle des moquettes c'est à dire des
gens qui ont qui n'ont pas encore de
grade puisqu'ils sont tous tout frais
issus issue de leur formation
merci madame sophie chasse oui monsieur
crasse monsieur benalla a fait état de
de tensions avec l'administration de
l'elysée tout à l'heure dans la presse
aussi il y a quelques semaines et
j'aurais voulu savoir si vous en aviez
connaissance à l'époque et à quoi vous
la tribouille et mathieu kreiss moi je
n'ai je n'ai aucune connaissance de
tensions particulières entre monsieur
benalla et d'autres personnes moi
personnellement je n'ai eu aucune
friction aucune tension dans mon service
je pense que vous avez audi auditionné
le général bio-farina qu'a pu vous vous
dire qu'en globalité il était satisfait
de moi j'ai été notés comme le sont les
officiers pas comme le sont tous les
gendarmes
tous les ans j'ai une notation plus que
satisfaisante pas fait état de en ce qui
me concerne donc une friction
en ce qui concerne monsieur benalla je
sais pas je peux pas vous répondre
mais à mon avis non ça se passait plutôt
bien voire très bien madame benbassa ma
dernière question
je voulais savoir monsieur craint
qu'elle qui avez vous participé à la
marche de madame claude
alors je ne sais pas qui est cette
madame octobre si la personne qui était
assassiné jeune juif alors c'est
peut-être bien pour le désire avez vous
participé à la négative
voilà très bien la question que je
n'avais pas participé à cette marche
la question était simple et la réponse
est je pense qu'il ya une confusion
c'est absolument enfin oui je vous pose
la question en toute bonne foi qui est
madame knoll parce que je vois là je ne
savais pas et bien je vous remercie
monsieur kerrouche mes secrets vous nous
confirmer que vous ne portez pardon
super forme et la question vous nous
confirmer que vous n'avez pas de port
d'armé jamais jugé utile de demander
alors messieurs grâce je ne répondrai
pas à cette question parce qu'elle est
en lien direct avec ma défense très bien
ça me parait rigoureux il n'y a pas
d'autres questions mes chers collègues
et bien dans ce cas monsieur kraz il ne
me reste plus qu'à vous remercier
d'avoir coopéré avec la commission des
lois investi de pouvoirs des commissions
d'enquêté et nous allons procéder
maintenant à l'audition le suivante
celle de monsieur yann drouet en sa
qualité d'ancien chef de cabinet du
préfet de police